[Música]
la pregunta la pregunta la fuente más
importante de creación es aquella que
permite que expand que da posibilidades
por eso digo comenzar esta charla al
hacerles a ustedes una pregunta para que
cada uno se responda y al hacerlo no lo
respondan como ese desconocido si no
responde hacerlo a ustedes mismos la
pregunta entonces es
quién tú eres y elige ser y de nuevo van
a responder como diciendo yo soy
valentina 29 años estudie esto y trabajé
en aquello sino por el contrario quién
tú realmente eres cuál es tú yo soy más
genuino
difícil pregunta pero abismales
implicaciones pues puede ser la pregunta
más importante en nuestra vida y
permítanme decirles por qué afirmo esto
al compartir una escena de la historia
de alicia en el país de las maravillas'
alicia en el momento estaba perdida no
sabía por qué camino tomar sin embargo
se encontró un gato
a esta lista le pregunta gato qué camino
debería tomar el gato le responde eso
dependan de quieras ir no sé a dónde
quiero ir no me importa ah bueno
entonces cualquier camino te funciona
esta pregunta es una analogía esta
historia discúlpeme es una analogía a
esta pregunta que nos estamos haciendo
si nosotros estamos buscando crear esa
vida más perfecta o ideal que cada uno
quiere entonces como mínimo debemos
saber quiénes somos y elegimos ser sino
si no nos quejemos o nos frustramos por
eso que no está pasando en la vida pues
tan solo es una muestra de que no
tenemos quedaría en nosotros
y si llegásemos a tener una certeza de
esto entonces la fórmula más próxima que
utilizamos es esta
hacer más tener es igual a cero es decir
entre ellos más allá y más tenga yo más
soy más r sin embargo la vida misma nos
ha mostrado por la experiencia que éste
no es así trabajamos y priorizamos
frenéticamente por un llenado de cosas
de hacer y tener estudio trabajo familia
dinero y muchas otras más no obstante
por más de que tenemos esas casillas no
somos siempre una ausencia siempre hay
algo más que hacer y tener
comenzamos a trabajar tanto en esto que
perdimos la noción y él lo que comienza
a gobernar es el estrés ahora toca la
frustración si hubiera todo para ver
cómo la vida se pasa frente a nuestros
ojos sin siquiera darnos cuenta
entonces
cómo se responde esta pregunta quién yo
soy como lo logró
estas fueron justamente preguntas que me
hice hace unos años
en el 2018 está trabajando una compañía
increíble tenía un saber envidiable una
hermosísima deja por muchos lugares no
obstante justamente no sentía que era
había esa ausencia y con el pasar del
tiempo comencé a sentir que había como
un sentimiento muy suave que susurraba y
que me decía que si había algo más
verdadero más grande en principio no lo
escuché pues no neguemos que los
manjares son placeres deliciosos pero
también con el pasar del tiempo esto
comenzó a ser tan grande que habían
situaciones ya difíciles crisis
problemas y tenía dos opciones o una
lidia va con esos síntomas y trataba de
seguir mi vida regular o dos comenzaba a
ir a una causa raíz y escuchar eso que
me decía que había algo más grande
decidirme por la segunda opción pero
esto implica que tenía que dejar muchas
cosas
renuncia a mi trabajo
renuncie también a muchas relaciones que
tenían y sobre todo decidí tomar una
maleta para comenzar un viaje de tratar
de responder eso inició el viaje fue una
experiencia increíble
comencé a conocer lugares en donde en
medio del mar hacia las montañas para
perderse con laberintos comencé a
recordar como la felicidad puede brotar
en medio de la escasez y aprendí cómo
podemos realmente manifestar esos sueños
que tenemos aprendí conocí muchísimo no
obstante todavía estaba esa pregunta
sentía que todavía faltaba algo y lo
entendí cuando sucedió un evento muy
particular
encontraban vietnam
decidí recorrerla en moto de sur a norte
2000 kilómetros y en mi día número 13
recorrido me encontraba con un amigo
andando como un día normal cuando yo
decido mover mi cabeza para volver a ver
la vía sucedió algo que nunca hubiera
creído
una gallina así es una gallina es
incluso la caché la regla de oro es ser
una y marc se te cruza trata de no
maniobrar sino el accidente puede ser
peor no obstante fue como una perfecta
sincronía entre la gallina y esa llanta
delantera a tal punto que la gallina se
traba en la llanta y comience a caer
comencé a sentir como todo mi cuerpo
para ver la moto en medio del pavimento
a propósito responde una pregunta que
todo me hace no desafortunadamente la
gallina no sobrevivió y desde ahí no
como pollo bueno está bien acepto que
silva com pero el hecho es que esta
situación me mostró de que si realmente
quería responder esa pregunta tenía que
parar un poco dejar de seguir
experimentando para comenzar a integrar
y entender eso más grande
y todo se dio cuando un evento que nos
detuvo a todos que nos hizo pensar
llegó la pandemia me encontraba en laos
un lugar llamado las 4000 islas ya
podría imaginar lo bello que es
me levanté como un día normal sin
embargo con una pequeña diferencia
comencé a ver a todos los mochileros
corriendo un lado a otro pregunté qué
sucedía me decían dmitri están cerrando
las fronteras en europa y en sureste
asiático en los siguientes días
comencé a ver la gente desesperada
comenzando a hablar con su familia
tratando de buscar vuelos mientras eso
se cancelaban había miedo ansiedad y ahí
decidí tomar otra decisión no decidí
volverme sino quedarme para seguir
buscando eso que decía que era más
genuino
decía él quiero una casita en tailandia
para estar por 5 meses a propósito
también responde una pregunta que tome
us no lo encontré a wilson la pelota de
náufrago por más que me parezca él
pero
si encontré esa respuesta a la pregunta
que no estamos haciendo
justamente durante esos cinco meses me
permití ser mediante la escritura la
reflexión que comencé a entender
quién tú eres y elige sister que
significa esa pregunta quién yo soy por
eso elijo aquí y ahora compartir eso que
yo entendí eso que yo recordé
ser
antes que nada es importante aclarar
algo en la serie tener no son malos no
son negativos por más de que aparezcan
villanos en mi historia realmente el
único villano es
uno mismo
el error no está en el objeto o en el
herramienta sino en el sujeto y como le
damos utilidad por dar un ejemplo una
silla sirve para sentarse y descansar
pero también sirve para golpear y matar
por ende no juzguemos en la serie tener
sino más bien démosle conciencia de cómo
lo estamos utilizando
luego de esto ahora hay que entender los
tres elementos más importantes e innatos
del ser es decir tres formas que
utilizarlas al experimentar las somos
existimos
el primero es pensar todo pensamiento
toda interpretación
creencia visualización cuando suceden es
una ejemplificación una muestra de que
somos el segundo elemento es el sentir
toda emoción y sentimiento cuando lo
experimentamos estamos experimentando
esa realidad quiénes somos y tercero es
el actuar y actuar incluye es hacer y
tener pero va más allá pues contiene el
tomar decisiones
el tomar riesgos y los hábitos
pensar sentir y actuar la trinidad de la
creación en la forma como nosotros somos
día a día así sea de manera inconsciente
inclusive ahora mismo no obstante formas
de que las tengamos y las apliquemos no
significa que somos eso más genuino que
uno es para lograr eso más auténtico y
verdadero entonces tenemos que utilizar
estas tres herramientas de una forma
específica la primera es usar el pensar
al trascender esas creencias que nos
limitan hoy en día vivimos bajo patrones
ideas de lo que es bueno y malo correcto
incorrecto es como una maceta que nos
limita a crecer a un bonsai y esto lo
que me pasaba yo creía que ganaría
exitosa y cuando habla con la gente lo
que quería hacer me decía que estaba
loco y cómo iba a dejar esta vida
el segundo es al comenzar a sentir eso
que sentimos y negamos y con esto no me
refiero sentir esa emoción cuando el
equipo gana o placer cuando me como un
helado sino eso más verdadero esa voz
que su sur pero es permanente y que
usualmente consideramos como tonterías
como me pasó a mí que sentía que era un
camino más grande más elevado
y el tercero es al actuar al permitirse
decidir en coherencia y esto hace
referencia a que toca estar alineado ese
pensamiento y sentimiento con el acto no
basta sólo con pensar y sentir
visualmente esto incluye muchos riesgos
como me pasó renunciar a un trabajo o
hace otras cosas diferentes no significa
que toca hacer esto pero usualmente
están muy relacionadas con incertidumbre
porque justamente estamos comenzando a
trascender nuestros pensamientos y por
primera vez sentir ese sentimiento
sincero
cuando comenzamos a utilizar estas
herramientas de esta manera entonces
comenzamos a hacer eso más gm es decir
comenzamos a reconocer honrar y vivir
eso verdadero uno al desvelar y
manifestarlo aquí y ahora
y esto no significa que hay un ser único
e ideal es decir no significa que el que
más me haya se cuelgue de quien más
medite el que más cambios líderes y que
más personas ayude es ese ser más
genuino no puede serlo para alguien pero
no significa que es el objetivo para
todos es al final permitirse manifestar
eso más auténtico y que hoy en día no
nos permitimos y puede ser desde esta
madre de amor incondicional con ese niño
que tiene condiciones especiales o es
artista que quiere ayudar a despertar
mediante el arte sin necesidad de ser
famoso
[Música]
de esta forma es que yo pude comenzar a
crear y entender cuál era mi ser más
genuino y yo soy yo soy despertar yo soy
consciencia yo soy creación
mi mayor esencia es poder justamente
ayudará a despertar esa conciencia de
cada uno de nosotros para poder crear
nos
y esto es un proceso es una creación
constante no hay un fin de la misma
manera esto no significa que yo no tengo
problemas o situaciones difíciles claro
que si la sigo teniendo y todavía sigo
pagando impuestos sin embargo esto no me
define pues ya una mucho referencia con
eso externó sino yo con algo interno de
la misma manera esto no significa que no
haga y tenga claro que si me encanta ir
a bailar y cuando lo siento voy y bailo
si me gusta una camisa me la compro pero
esto no me determina por que poseo y
hago cosas pero estas cosas no me poseen
no me as
esta historia esto que les estoy
compartiendo ustedes me pasó a mí pero
nos puede pasar a cualquiera si y sólo
si nos permitimos ser nos permitimos ser
ese pensamiento más elevado ese
sentimiento más sincero y ese acto más
coherente y cuando lo hagamos entonces
comenzamos a decir
eureka pues comenzaremos a entender
quién realmente somos y en el camino no
esperaremos a que ese campo ese
catedralicia nos diga a dónde ir si no
le diremos a él qué camino estamos
tomando para así finalmente recordar una
vez más que yo soy muchísimas gracias
[Música]